another huge superhero movie another
huge superhero movie spoiler talk and
that is a solid spoiler wording for
x-men apocalypse if you have not seen
x-men apocalypse yet you're gonna get
some spoilers here warning leave now or
don't hey how you doing let's talk
spoiler so x-men apocalypse has come it
is landed the x-men are determined to
cancel the apocalypse so we're gonna get
a couple things in x-men apocalypse big
baddie who wants to destroy everything
and the origin for some x-men that we
didn't see the origin of before but the
origin that's not an origin that we're
actually interested in just the
character depth was Magneto's story
Mendes spoiler talk isn't beat by Pete
talking about the movie we're gonna skip
to some magneto [ __ ] magneto story was
pretty cool he's laid down arms like you
know what I'm going under an alias I
have a wife I have a kid I just want to
live my life he's not using his powers
but she knows he is or was Magneto
is what they're honest with each other
they have a pretty good marriage pretty
good life living the dream in the
wilderness until this big [ __ ] molten
metal thing almost falls on a dune he
uses magnetic power and saves the guy's
life and he's like [ __ ] we gotta go and
even though he uses powers to save a
life people are afraid and people like
well you are Magneto you've done some
[ __ ] just saying so they're not gonna
let it stand they go and confront him
and his daughter who's like not really
Scarlet Witch starts talking to birds
like she goes Alfred Hitchcock and birds
start swarming around just dude let's
the bow and arrow go daughter gets
plugged in the back through the Wi-Fi
magneto loses his entire family with one
arrow like it's the beginning of the
revenant or some [ __ ] I was like oh they
went there they uh you're all dead sorry
hope it's been a good life because
you're toast now sure enough magneto
wipes them all out apocalypse uses that
pain to recruit magneto as one of his
four horsemen now they're gonna wreak
some [ __ ] which involving magneto if I'm
skipping to the end of the movie is a
wasted opportunity with Quicksilver the
whole time quicksilver's like he's my
father I want to confront him if not
talk to him and in the end he doesn't
actually confront magneto he doesn't
tell them hey I'm your kid I mean
Magneto's lost everything he feels like
he has no family left it would have been
a pretty cool thing for him to be like
you do have family I am your family then
that could've been a good reason for
magneto to be like yeah let's not wreck
the world magneto ends up you know turn
coding on apocalypse we just that never
happens it never goes there because of
that kind of bummed me out he does kick
the [ __ ] out of apocalypse though that
was pretty sweet you're like Quicksilver
sir why wouldn't Quicksilver just zip
around and just start punching
apocalypse he starts doing that epochal
gets the better of him but at least
showed that he tried because you know if
Quicksilver didn't try to kick the [ __ ]
out of apocalypse people were like why
didn't he try to keep the [ __ ] out of
apocalypse oh now that just can't happen
that is the Internet so it will
regarding the four horsemen though I
would have liked more character on a
couple like Magneto we get the story on
storm we get a bit of an introduction to
so that was pretty cool not in-depth
introduction but introduction enough
[ __ ] and Archangel man they're there
to be muscled pretty much for granted
the movies already 2 hours and 45
minutes long granted for me at least it
didn't feel like 2 hours and 45 minutes
long which is a good testament to the
movie yet show everything I guess
whatever skip into epochal apocalypse
wants to wreck everybody but like I said
in my spoiler free review he doesn't
actually start killing mutants when he
could you could see that as when he says
hey you're all my children and I want to
bring you out of this shitty state so
we're gonna wipe out the world and build
a better one I just feel like if the
x-men are being enough of a nuisance he
could have made the column be like yeah
you know what though those kids has got
to die cuz if I don't wipe them out
they're gonna ruin my plan just kind of
make sense if you're thinking like an
[ __ ] didn't do that sometimes I'm
watching a movie I'm like they're right
let's get into the mind of an [ __ ]
yeah you should have killed him weird
thing is when you start seeing
inconsistencies is that Moira in this
movie has no memory of ever meeting
Charles Xavier
apparently but only she did an x-men
first class she did remember meeting him
she's had no memory of the huge [ __ ]
that went down and even if she didn't
remember him the dude she was talking to
the CIA it was like you mean he can do
that he can just wipe your mind and
that's it at the very least he would
have informed her is like oh by he I
mean Charles Xavier who you met but an
x-men apocalypse she has no idea that
she's ever had contact with Charles
Xavier kind of saw that as an
inconsistency but kind of I mean I do
seem like at the end of Days of Future
past you're under the impression alright
this timeline is now what we're dealing
with here at the end of Days of Future
past Stryker didn't actually get
Wolverine that Stryker turns around he's
like I'll tiger from here then his eyes
glow yellow so you know he's mystique so
Stryker never actually got Wolverine but
apparently Stryker did get Wolverine
because there's a pretty sweet cameo in
this movie you having the kids were in
the helicopter I was like oh they're
gonna go to alkali lake and that's why
you see Wolverines another reason I wish
they hadn't shown Wolverine because when
they were going in the helicopter I was
like alkali Lake Wolverine cameo holy
[ __ ] it's going to show us the Weapon X
outraged by outrage I mean slaughter and
that's exactly how it went down it was
pretty sweet though when it starts
panning up you see the cables and the
weapon
helmut I was like oh this is pretty
legit right here and you can totally see
what he wants to crush that Jean Gregg's
Jean helps him out however he doesn't
remember alkali like otherwise he would
have all the answers to his questions so
he apparently doesn't start getting a
memory that sticks past short-term for a
little bit for a while at least she just
has an affinity for redheads doesn't
know what anything is in the end the
world's still got his ass kicked you
think they're gonna be like all right so
that Sentinel programmed we want to Bri
up that [ __ ] I mean above our trash
getting shot in the head was gonna push
that program forward what about that
time a mutant almost ripped the earth in
half like a [ __ ] clay ball with
magnetism because apocalypse did some
damage not enough damage if you ask me
that's the thing that irritated me oh
really the irritants in this movie are
the things that irritated me because I
wanted to see some things with
apocalypse that I didn't see example in
the trailer it shows him growing big
when he fights Charles Xavier turns out
that's just in their heads yeah
apocalypse and Xavier psychically linked
and so they go into each other's heads
and they have a mental fight pretty much
that's when he grows big he never
actually grows big in the real world but
apocalypse skin and does grow big in the
real world I figure could have done more
damage would have made a more menacing
if he did that in the real world but I
did like how the movie wrapped up I am
NOT gonna lie I'm a fan of that [ __ ]
when Jean Grey was walking forward
Xavier is like Jean help me help me I
was like holy [ __ ] fire fire fire fire
fire if you look at her dreams that she
was having at the beginning of the
movies like all this death all this
destruction and all of it was with fire
you could pass it off as psychic imagery
maybe like metaphorically speaking it's
like Apocalypse is gonna do damage Jean
just saw it as fire the fact that it was
fire I was like is she seeing apocalypse
visions or is she seeing her own Phoenix
visions yeah I think we're leading up to
the Phoenix saga I like this I did see
that she glimpsed Apocalypse really
briefly that's not to say the whole
visions of fire were actually apocalypse
babies you see in the Phoenix [ __ ] and
the apocalypse [ __ ] I don't know all I
know is I saw fire ice off Phoenix at
the end of the movie Phoenix happens but
yeah which is all bands of Phoenix fire
comes out I was like holy [ __ ] it's the
[ __ ] Phoenix let me think the girl
sitting next to me was like it's the
Mockingjay I was like oh you've gotta be
[ __ ] kidding us talking [ __ ] did it
[ __ ] is the Phoenix that predates the
Mockingjay by a very long time what else
could stop apocalypse hey she just kind
of disassembles him at the cellular
level it's like yeah grow back
that [ __ ] healer but that sets up for
the Phoenix saga and I hope they do the
Phoenix saga and I hope Brian singer
does the Phoenix saga there are theories
that he didn't want to do x-men
apocalypse but he wouldn't have gotten
the budget for the movie he wanted to do
unless you did x-men apocalypse but if
that is the case you gotta at least do
the Phoenix saga dude remember what
happened last time you didn't get to do
the Phoenix saga you should probably do
the Phoenix saga the build up of x-men 1
and 2 obviously shows that he wanted to
do the Phoenix saga in the build up of
this one shows that he probably still
wants to do the Phoenix saga although
the studio probably wants the Phoenix
saga to happen because what are they
going to do after apocalypse other than
the Phoenix saga I just want to see
Bryan Singer get his chance to do the
Phoenix saga and at the end of the movie
when it shows them all lined up wasn't
that sweet that was just sweet as hell I
mean I'm a 90s x-men fan it's when I
watched the cartoon that's when I knew
the x-men and those suits at the end of
the movie are straight-up 90s x-men
suits not just black leather for the
sake of black leather because black
leather is cool know it they're actually
x-men character suits and the x-men
post-credit scene is pretty sweet there
is a post-credits scene in x-men
apocalypse it does give me pause and
makes me wonder like alright so was the
wolverine cameo always planned or were
they not gonna have it they were like
hey we want to do x-23 we need to lead
up to it if we're gonna lead up to it we
might as well have a really sweet cameo
by Hugh Jackman the point is these men
in black these government guys go to
alkali lake they take Logan's blood and
it put it in a briefcase and that's the
end but just build up to x-23 she
Wolverine she marine this what I'm gonna
call it but wait there's more than men
in Black's briefcase was marked with the
Essex Corporation logo so this mr.
sinister to bring it in so they're also
bringing sinister and sinister gonna be
the next baddie is Phoenix gonna be the
next Betty have we seen all we're gonna
see if Phoenix I hope not but I also
want to see sinister we're gonna get
clothes what clothes we're gonna get
including but not limited to x-23 the
possibilities guys in the end x-men
apocalypse was thoroughly enjoyable I
enjoyed the hell out of the movie not
gonna lie Rock tomatoes I just don't get
that [ __ ] well I don't base [ __ ] on
Rotten Tomatoes really how rotten
tomatos works if you guys didn't know it
really is like let's say a movie has 90%
on Rotten Tomatoes this means 90% of the
critics liked the movie 90% of the
critics gave it at least a 60% it's
white that [ __ ] just doesn't mean much
to me I mean the movie has its flaws for
sure but x-men apocalypse did what I
wanted x-men apocalypse to do more or
less generally speaking that's all I can
ask for
alright guys finishing
the spoiler talk x-men apocalypse have
you seen it what's your favorite part in
x-men apocalypse whatever it is whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more